The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
OK, let's get started.
So today we're going to talk
about measurement and timing.
And I want to start out by
just showing you a study
that one of my students did--
actually, at that point,
he was a former student--
whereas timing a
code for sorting.
So here's the code.
This isn't exactly his code,
but it's in the same spirit
so that you get the idea.
And so let's just
run through this code
and take a look to
see what it's doing.
It's pretty straightforward.
We're going to use the time.h
header file to get access
to the clock_gettime() routine,
which is going to be what we
used to get timing measurements.
And then we have
a sorting routine
that we're going to time.
That I'm not showing you.
And there is also
a fill routine,
which is going to fill up
the array with numbers--
with random numbers, so
we have something to sort.
And the clock_gettime() uses
a struct that is defined here,
and so I'm defining two timing
structs-- a start and an end.
So this is just absolute
boilerplate setting up
for taking timing measurements.
And in this case, basically the
high order part of the struct
tells the seconds, the lower
part tells the nanoseconds.
And then we're
going to loop over
arrays of increasing length.
And then what we're going
to do is fill them up--
oh, I forgot the fill-- and then
we're going to measure how much
time--
what the time is
just before we sort.
Then we're going to
sort, and then we're
going to measure the
time after sorting.
And then we compute
the difference,
and figure out what the elapsed
time is, print that out,
and then we do it again for
a little bit larger array.
So is that clear
what's going on?
So we're just sorting
a bunch of numbers,
then we're sorting
some bigger ones,
sorting some bigger
ones, so we can
see what the growth of the
sorting routine should be.
People have a pretty
good understanding
of what the code does?
OK, so what do we expect to see?
What's this curve
going to look like?
What are some properties of it?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
So micro is n log n,
but it's certainly
going to grow, right?
It should be up
and to the right.
In fact, one rule, if you
ever get into marketing,
is that all graphs must
go up and to the right.
If they're going down
and to the right,
then your company's in trouble.
So it should be going
up and to the right,
and it should follow,
for example, n log n,
if it's an n log n sort,
which is what this one was.
I think he was, in this
case, timing a merge sort.
They should go up
and to the right,
and should follow n
log n, or whatever.
So let's see what
actually happened
when he took the measurements.
This is actually his data from--
gosh, this must have been
20 years ago or something.
Here's what it looked like.
So the blue Xs there
are the runtimes.
And then through that,
we've plotted two curves,
one which is the
best fit to order n
log n growth, and the best
fit to order n growth.
You notice that for--
even though we're going
up to 4 million here,
there's not that much difference
between n log n and order n.
You can see it mostly
down in the tails.
Definitely the n log n
follows a little bit better,
but really, log n is
pretty small already.
But wow, those measured times--
so if you look, there
are points way up here--
really slow.
It starts out-- it
goes slow a little bit,
and then it gets a little bit
worse, and then a little bit
worse, and a little bit worse.
Notice also that the bumps
are getting closer and closer
together.
What is going on?
Why?
I don't know about
you, but I thought
the data would follow the
green dots reasonably closely.
But you can see it doesn't.
It's always good to
have a model for what
you think is going on
because then, when you--
because some people
will just take numbers.
They'll say, here's
my numbers for my--
that I've measured.
And if you don't
actually have a model
for what those
numbers mean, you're
probably fooling yourself.
You're more likely to have
made some sort of error,
or there's something
going on that you're not
observing, or whatever,
if you don't actually
have a model for what you
think should be going on.
So what's going on here?
Who can suggest a hypothesis
for what is going on?
So he took these numbers
on his laptop, by the way.
What do you suppose
is happening here?
Some ideas.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Maybe
it doesn't fit in the cache.
What would you expect
to happen if things
didn't fit in the cache?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Yeah, you sort of
think that it would go along,
and then it would jump.
So interesting issue, but
that doesn't seem to be what's
happening there.
It's going up, then
it's going back down.
It's going up and
going back down--
roller coaster.
What other ideas are there?
Good idea.
Let's think a little bit about
what's going on in the machine.
What are some other good ideas?
Or bad ideas?
Let's eliminate some.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They're
not powers of 2.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
They're not powers of 2.
These are not
powers of 2, right?
Because they're getting
closer and closer as
we get bigger and bigger.
Yeah, so you're right.
It's not correlated
with powers of 2.
Weird.
Because sometimes things
are alignment issues,
and we'll talk more about that.
It will come up when we talk
about caching after the quiz.
Everybody knows there's
a quiz next time--
especially all of
you who aren't here?
OK, so what else might be
going on in the machine here?
Because this is reality.
This is what happens when
you take measurements.
So we're being very nice to you.
We're giving you AWS run.
We have done everything
we can to make
sure those numbers come
out clean, and beautiful,
and untouched.
There they are.
That is quality measurements
we're taking for you.
But if you had to
do it yourself,
that's what this lecture,
in part, is about.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
So you think
that there may be something
having to do with the cache.
But I'm going through each time
and I'm refilling the array
each time, so they're kind of
starting from a clean slate--
similar clean slate each time.
What else is going on
in the machine here?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] totally
unrelated stuff [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Yeah, there
could be totally
unrelated stuff running.
You might have daemons, you
might have all kinds of things,
and so forth.
So he thought of
that, and he shut down
everything he possibly could.
And this is what he got still.
But that's a great idea
because often, there's
some external things going on.
In this case, it's
called multi-tenancy.
There's more than one thing
using the computer at a time.
Good idea, but happens
not to be the one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Could
be precision with the timing.
Yeah, sometimes there
can be issues there,
but this was not
a precision issue.
He could have used
a really dumb timer
and gotten something
very similar to this.
What else is going
on your machine?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe his
machine's checking
for updates every minute.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Yeah, maybe it's
checking for updates.
That's once again
some external things.
No, it wasn't
checking for updates.
Wasn't checking for updates.
What is going on here?
What is going on?
Let's have some more ideas.
What other things might
disrupt measurements?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Yeah.
This was actually merge
sort he was timing,
so there's no randomization.
But even that, if
it were quick sort,
it'd be at random that things
would tend to take longer,
rather than following
this crazy pattern.
What is causing
that crazy pattern?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does the random
fill have to do with the time?
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: No,
because the random fill
is done outside the timer.
Each time through
the loop, we fill,
and then we start
the timer, and then
we take the measurement,
and so forth.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: It's
not allocating memory.
But that's an interesting
idea, because sometimes you
have things going on where
you think things are happening
right away, but the system is
being clever and delaying it.
And so you end up paying
for it at some later time,
and that could possibly
create something.
Turns out not to be
what's going on here.
So what's happening here
is that the machine is
changing the clock frequency.
Why is the machine changing
the clock frequency?
Your laptops change the--
the systems that we have,
they change clock frequency.
Why do they change it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Because
the laptop is getting hot.
So what do are doing?
We're running something
computational.
And the smaller ones--
OK, we get a lot of those done,
until it starts heating up,
and so it slows down the
system clock to save power.
OK, and then what happens?
Slows it down a little bit,
cools off a little bit,
starts to speed up again.
And then we run longer.
And why are these things getting
closer and closer together?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Takes longer and
longer to run the sorts.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Yeah,
it takes longer and longer
to run the sorts,
so you're going
to see the effect
closer in an interval
here, even if it happened
to be equal in time.
Even if it was
equal in time, we're
doing bigger and
bigger problems.
This is nuts, right?
We want to take measurements.
We want to know whether
the software is faster.
What are you supposed to do?
So here, if you just took
a measurement and said,
look, this is the time that
it takes me to run this code,
you would be hugely missing
the boat, if you were taking
one of those high measurements.
You compare A to
B. You run A first,
then you run B. B is slower.
Oh, well, that's
because when you ran A,
it heated up the processor, so
the processor slowed it down.
So this particular
architectural feature
is called DVFS, dynamic
frequency and voltage scaling.
It's a technique to reduce
power by adjusting the clock
frequency and supply
voltage to transistors.
So the idea is that,
if the chip ends up
getting too hot, or in
the case of laptops,
often if you want
to conserve battery,
it chooses to slow
down the clock.
And the second thing it can
do is reduce the voltage,
if the frequency is reduced.
So when you're actually
running slower,
you can actually get the
same reliability of switching
with a lower voltage.
At a higher voltage--
sorry-- at higher
clock frequencies
you need enough voltage to
make sure those electrons are
scooting across the transistor
junctions fast enough.
So the basic power law that
the electrical engineers--
is anybody here an
electrical engineer?
OK.
There's good stuff in
EE, let me tell you.
So those of you who
are too embarrassed
to raise your
hands, I support EE.
So power goes as CV squared
f, where C is what's
called the dynamic capacitance.
There's actually
another term, which
is the static capacitance,
which doesn't have to deal
with frequency or whatever.
But for the dynamic
power, it's CV squared f.
It's the dynamic capacitance.
It's roughly the area
of the circuitry times
how many bits are moving.
So if bits don't move,
they don't consume power,
for dynamic power.
And then V is the
supply voltage, and then
f as the clock frequency.
So if you can reduce the
frequency and voltage,
you get a cubic reduction
in power, and also in heat.
Who thinks their battery
doesn't last long enough?
Yeah, OK.
Wouldn't be nice if
they lasted a month?
So you can see why they're
motivated to play this game--
to save the battery or to run
things as hot as they can.
But if it gets too hot,
we'll just back off.
But for performance measurement,
this is basically a nightmare.
It wreaks havoc.
So the topic of today's lecture
is how can one reliably measure
the performance of software,
when you have stuff like this
going on in our system?
Now, the good thing
about something like DVFS
is there's actually ways of
shutting it off and taking
measurements.
You probably pay some
performance for doing that,
because they can basically--
who's ever worked
on an overclocked system?
Some of you game players, right?
So part of the game--
the idea there, when they're
overclocking it, is let's
keep--
get things cool and so forth.
And there's lots of
games like this that are
played and overclocked systems.
So I'm going to talk
about three topics today.
One is about quiescing
systems, which
is making them quiet enough that
we can take good measurements,
getting rid of
some of the noise.
And that second I
talk about some tools
for measuring
software performance,
and then we'll talk a bit
about performance modeling.
So I hope this is a
little motivational.
Boy, you think you've
seen it all sometimes,
and then somebody presents you
with a puzzle, and it's like,
what's going on?
And then takes a
little detective work
to figure out that that's
actually what's going on.
So we'll start first
about quiescing systems.
Who knows who
Genichi Taguchi was?
Anybody here?
No?
He's very famous because he's
the one who made our automobile
industry produce reliable cars.
Very, very famous fellow.
He did a lot of
different things.
I'm going to point out one of
the things that he observed.
And it's in the
context of suppose
you were an Olympic
pistol coach,
and you've got two shooters--
A and B-- and you
look at their targets.
And here's A's target.
Oh, he hit the bulls-eye.
Good.
And if you add that up, he's
got a pretty decent score.
Then you look at B. B didn't
even hit the bullseye,
and his score is really lousy.
Who do you want on
your team, A or B?
Who do you want?
AUDIENCE: You would
pick B, just because he
could adjust the sights.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Yeah, because it's
easy to tell him what to do.
You adjust the sights.
You teach him to shoot down a
little bit lower to the left.
It's easy to diagnose
what his problem is.
That's all you have to do.
What do you do for A?
It's not clear what you do.
And so what he did in the realm
of quality control was say,
look, when we're
producing products,
before we try to fix the
reliability, or whatever is,
of the product--
increase the quality
let's first reliably
produce whatever
we're producing so we get
the same thing every time.
Because then we can go in
and see what the problem is,
and we can adjust for it.
And so the idea is go
after the variance first.
Go after the spread.
Try to get the spread
as small as possible.
Try to figure out how it
is that you can isolate--
produce the same thing,
even if it's not very good.
And then go and try
to make changes.
Because if you try
to make changes
while you have high
variance, you don't even
know if you're making
progress or not,
because it could be in the
noise of your measurements.
Now, in the context of
performance engineering,
if you can reduce
variability, you
can do things like compensate
for systematic and random
measurement errors.
And you can also do things
like not run as many trials
to discover whether one
program is better than another.
So a lot of advantages
to being able to
have really quiet things.
It's kind of obvious
that you should
want to have reliable
measurements,
but there's actually, as I say,
a theory behind it for wide
is that you want to
have quiet measurements,
and what you need to focus on.
Now, in our computer
systems, there
are lots of sources
of variability,
and some people came up
with some of them here.
Let me mention just
a few of them here.
So there are things like daemons
and background jobs, things
that are running on your system
that are helping the system
to do whatever it's doing.
Many of them are unnecessary,
and those can be running--
so for example, maybe
you set up a chron job
to do something for
you every night,
and that happens to be
just when you happen
to be making some measurements.
Well, that's not really
good, because you're now
sharing the resource.
Interrupts-- something comes in.
I had one time where
we were measuring stuff
on the connection machine
CM5, which in its day,
was the world's most
powerful computer.
1993, it was the top of the
list of the supercomputers.
And now this computer
is more powerful.
Cost $43 million or something.
Moore's law has really
made a difference.
And we were measuring the
performance of something,
and we kept getting
these anomalous results.
And eventually, we
tracked it down.
It took us a lot of work,
but we tracked it down.
The graduate student
who was running it,
while he was running it, he
was moving the mouse around.
And when you moved the
mouse, it was interrupting
200 times a second to deal
with the interrupts that
was interfering with
our measurements.
True story.
We disconnected
the network even so
that we wouldn't
get external things,
and we're still
getting this thing.
What is going on?
And eventually, we tracked
it down to that fact
that he was just
sitting there idling--
so it's like, start it
up, and then hands off.
It was like, nobody move.
Code and data alignment--
where the code lies
affects its performance.
If a code goes across
two cache lines
versus completely
within one cache line,
that can have a difference,
depending upon what's
conflicting in the cache.
Or if you go across
page boundaries,
it can have a very big
difference, for example,
in the translation
lookaside buffer, TLB.
You may be going for
different entries.
There may be different
things there.
So code alignment can
make a difference in the--
what you're doing.
Thread placement-- if you
have a multicore machine,
which core is it running?
It turns out the
system likes to use
core 0 for a lot of its stuff.
So if you're going to take
reliable measurements,
don't run on core 0.
Runtime scheduler-- the
fact that, for example, we
have a randomized
scheduler, which
means that there's
random numbers going on
so you're going to try
to take measurements
in the midst of all
this randomness.
Hyperthreading-- hyperthreading
is where they take one core.
It's also called
symmetric multithreading--
or no, simultaneous
multithreading.
That's what it's called,
simultaneous multithreading,
or hyperthreading is
what Intel calls it.
What that is is they
have one functional unit,
and then they run two
instruction streams through it
at the same time, each with
its own set of registers,
but using the same
functional units.
And they get basically
a 20% speed up
or something from having--
it looks, from the
software point of view,
like you've got two
processors, but really
it only gives you
1.2 processors.
So it's one of
these things that,
by the way, if you start
counting up how many processors
and saying work over the
number of processors,
and you say, well, how
many processors do I have--
well, you may have just a
hyperthreaded processor,
rather than a real processor.
So one thing, for example,
in the cloud system
that you folks are
using, we turn off
hyperthreading so that we can
get more reliable measurements,
and so we can look
at the measurements
as a function of the
number of processors.
Multitenancy-- and
this is particularly
important in the cloud.
If you're in the cloud,
there are other people
using the system, they can
end up using lots of resources
that maybe you want, like cache.
And they can end up using
network traffic that
may affect you, and such.
I'm actually quite
amazed at how well Amazon
does in AWS in making
it so that that stuff
doesn't affect you very much.
Our numbers show that
they are, in fact--
they are definitely
the leader right now
in having repeatable
measurements,
compared to all the
cloud providers.
We talked about DVFS.
There's also another
one called Turbo Boost.
So Turbo Boost looks to see
how many jobs are actually
running on the multicore.
If there's only one job
running on the multicore,
it increases the clock
frequency for that job--
or if there's just a few.
As soon as another one comes
in, it slows things back down.
So it tries to give
a boost when you're
in executing serial
code because it
says, well, I'm not generating
heat from all the cores.
I just have to generate it
from the one that I've got.
I can afford to have
one of them run hotter.
Network traffic-- and
there's, by the way,
a bunch of other ones.
We're going to talk
about a few of these,
but first let me tell you
what the impact of quiescing
a system is.
So this is joint work that I
did in my group with Tim Kaler.
So we wrote a Cilk program
to count the primes
in an interval.
And we ran on a c4 instance,
18 cores-- similar to what
you're running with.
We had two-way
hyper-threading on.
Turbo Boost was on.
We had 18 Cilk workers.
We had 100 runs, each
about one second.
And what I've plotted here
is how much is the percent
that each run was.
We basically ran
100 runs, and then
I sorted them from
smallest run to largest.
And I normalized them to
whatever the minimum one
was so that each thing here is
a percentage above the minimum.
So you can see that the
slowest run was almost 25%
slower than the fastest run.
So you can see
what the impact is.
So 25%-- if you're trying to
produce a code by getting a 3%
improvement 30
times, you can't--
there's so much noise here.
It's very hard for you to figure
out that you're 3% faster.
So if you quiesce the
system, same thing.
We turn hyperthreading
off, turn Turbo Boost off,
and we quieted all the
daemons, and so forth.
Then out of 100 runs, we got
essentially the same value
every single time,
except for three times.
And notice that the
scale here has changed.
The scale here is now less
than 0.8%, less than 1% slower.
So this says that, hey, if I
took a couple of measurements,
I'm very likely to
hit something that
is the real running
time, which tends to be,
for this, what the
minimum is here.
Because all the other stuff is
noise that's just adding in.
Make sense?
So it is possible
to quiesce a system.
It's not that
hard, it just takes
a small matter of
programming and systems work.
So here are some tips
on how you quiesce
a system, if you wanted to
do this for your laptop,
for example.
Make sure no other
jobs are running.
Shut down daemons and cron jobs.
Disconnect the network.
Don't fiddle with the mouse.
For serial jobs, don't run
on core 0, where interrupt
handlers are usually run.
Turn hyperthreading off.
Turn off DVFS.
Turn off Turbo Boost.
Use taskset to pin
workers to cores.
So taskset is a
utility that says,
I want you to run this
thread on this core,
and don't let the operating
system bounce it around.
So normally, the operating
system maps threads to cores--
the workers, the Cilk workers--
to cores in any way
that it feels like.
This says, no, I want you
to have it exactly here so
that, when I run something else,
it's exactly the same thing.
And so forth.
And we've already done a lot
of this for you for AWS run.
By the way, there
is no way of getting
a completely
deterministic result out
of running on modern hardware.
Does anybody know why?
If I have a serial
program and it's
deterministic serial
program, and I set it up
and I reboot the system
so it's got exactly
the same content,
et cetera, I still
can get non-deterministic
results.
Does anybody know why?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: No,
you can turn that off.
So they actually do
randomize address space
for security reasons.
But when you run under
the debugger and so forth,
they tend to turn that off so
that you can get repeatability
for debugging purposes.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
No, those are generally--
no, those are
deterministic, but there
is something in the hardware
which is non-deterministic.
Does anybody know what
is, happen to know,
can guess what it is?
Something the hardware
that's non-deterministic.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Disk access would be,
but if I'm just running
something in core--
I'm not using disk,
I'm just going to run--
it turns out non-deterministic,
even though I'm just
running everything inside
with ordinary DRAM memory,
and so forth.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: No,
the out of order execution
is all deterministic.
There's no randomization there.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Branch prediction.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Branch
prediction's all deterministic
algorithms--
all deterministic.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The
system clock signal?
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: System
clock signal's very regular.
Very regular, if you turn
off DVFS and stuff like that.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: So the
Linus schedule is, in fact,
a deterministic algorithm.
And if you're just
running on one core,
the scheduler never
comes into it.
So there is one source
of non-determinism,
and that is memory errors.
So there's a chance that
one of your memory--
when you're accessing the
DRAM, that an alpha particle
collided with one of
the bits and flipped it.
And there's hardware in
there to do error correction,
but it takes an
extra cycle to do it.
So if it reads the
memory location,
discovers that there is an
error in what it read, then it
performs the correction,
and then you get it.
And that's something that's
completely non-deterministic,
because its alpha particle's
coming from outer space--
space aliens messing
with your system.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
No, actually--
now, most cache is covered
by error correction,
but the most
likely-- if you look,
the biggest memory is the DRAMs.
That's the most likely
source of these things.
So in any case, I
want to now just talk
about a few things which--
just some examples of things
that might come up for you.
So these are ones
that I've mentioned,
but I just want
to go through them
in a little bit more depth.
So one of the things
is code alignment
can make a difference.
So what happens is
you have your program,
and you make a
change that you think
is improving your program.
But what happens, let's say,
is that it causes an extra byte
to be put into the code.
So maybe the compiler
is very smart.
You made some little change.
Then everything that follows
it gets shifted down,
and so the cache
alignment issues
can be completely different.
Something can go across
a page boundary that
didn't used to go across
the page boundary,
and that can have a big
impact on your performance.
This is like, yikes.
This is like, yikes,
how am I supposed to--
maybe we should just pack up
on performance engineering.
So everybody gets what
the issue is there?
So in this case, I
inserted one byte.
Well, everything after that,
it's all linear in memory
would change.
Here's another one that's
even more insidious.
If you change the order in
which the .o files appear
on the linker command line,
that can actually have a bigger
effect than going between
minus 02 and minus 03.
And when you
compile, you compile
this order versus this order.
You can have actually
quite a big difference.
Yike, OK, so what do you do?
Well, first of all, one of
the things I'm glad to say
is that the compiler people
have recognized this,
and the situation is not as
dire as it was years ago.
What they do now very often is
do a lot of alignment already.
So for example, it's common
for compilers to produce--
to start every function on the
first word of a cache line.
That way, when
things get slid down,
you might apart
from one cache line
to the next for where it
starts, but you're not
going to affect the--
where you lie on the
cache line, which
can make a difference, by the
way, in branch predictors,
and things like that.
And so that helps.
That really quiets
a lot of things.
And in fact, they give
you some directives.
So LLVM has these switches.
As far as I could
tell, the first one,
which is align-all-functions,
I think--
I was unable to test
this in advance,
but I suspect that it's
actually already doing this
and this is actually a no
op, because it's already
aligning all functions.
I don't know that
for a fact, but you
can give the switch anyway,
which will help if I'm lying.
So that forces the
alignment of all functions.
So all functions start
on the cache line,
and that way, if you change one
function, it's unlikely to--
it won't change the cache
alignment of another function.
It will only change the cache
alignment of the function
that you're messing with.
You can also ask it to align
all blocks in the function.
So remember that, in LLVM,
we have these basic blocks,
these pieces of serial code
with links, the basic blocks.
So what it will do is
force every one of those
to be on a boundary.
But of course, what
that means is now
you've got a jump
between these codes,
even if it were going to
be the next instruction
or put in a bunch of no ops.
So that can
substantially increase
the size of your binary,
and it can slow you down.
But on the other hand, you'll
get very reliable results
from then on, because every
block is now cache-aligned.
Probably more
practical is to align--
is to force the alignment
of all blocks that have
no fall-through predecessors.
That is, you don't
have to add notes.
So this basically reduces it
to the ones that are usually
causing the trouble.
So a line of code is more likely
to avoid performance anomalies,
but it can also
sometimes be slower.
And so one of the
questions is, well,
which matters to you in
your particular thing?
Here's one that I love.
So the example that I gave
before of the order of linking,
we have that as a reading
assignment, by the way,
on the web, that paper.
And here's another result
from this paper by Mytkowicz
and his colleagues.
They have a wonderful paper
called Producing Wrong Data
Without Doing Anything
Obviously Wrong.
So one of the examples they
give [INAUDIBLE] the ordering
of things, saying that, look,
that actually had an impact
between 02 and 03.
The program's name can affect
its speed, and here's why.
The executable's name ends up
in an environment variable.
So when you start
up the program,
it puts it in an
environment variable.
The environment
variables, it turns out,
end up on the call stack.
So you can find out
from the program
what's the name of the
program I was invoked with.
The length of the name
affects the stack alignment.
You have a longer
name, they put longer--
a longer piece there.
And so if the data happens to
go across page boundaries--
some critical piece of data goes
on two pages, rather than one--
that could have a big
impact on your performance.
And there are other
data alignment problems
that can arise.
Yeah, this is kind
of nasty stuff.
So as I say, what we've done--
we've given you a
very quiesced system.
We have done everything
we can to make it so
that, when you submit stuff
in this class, it's measured.
But as we get along
in the semester
and you're doing more
sophisticated stuff,
some of this is going
to fall increasingly
to you to do things
that make it robust.
OK, let's move on.
We've talked about quiescing.
Now, let's talk a little
about tools for measuring
software performance.
So I did a little thinking, and
I figured that there's actually
about five different
ways I know of measuring
the performance of a program.
So one is you can measure
the program externally.
You can run the time command.
If you say time and then
give a shell command,
it will run the shell command
and then tell you at the end
how long it took.
You can instrument the program.
That means to actually put
timing calls into the program.
So you can use things
like clock_gettime,
which I recommend.
And we'll talk a little
bit about these other two,
gettimeofday and rdtsc.
And you can either do this
by hand where you say,
I'm going to time
something myself,
or it turns out you can have
compiler support for taking
timing measurements.
But what that involves is
changing the program in order
to put these timing calls in.
And of course, you
have the effect that,
if you're perturbing the--
if you're putting
these timing calls in,
you can be changing the timing.
So you've got that problem
to worry about, as well.
One of the ones is you
can interrupt the program.
One of the cheapest ways you
can do it's just basically
take gdb.
So you start running
your program.
You run it under gdb, and
then you type Control-C.
And then you look.
Where is the program?
And you do that a few
times, and you say, hey,
the same routine is always
where the code is running.
Oh, that must be where
it's spending all its time.
That's actually been put into
a thing called poor man's
profiler, and then
you can actually--
this is essentially the
method that gprof uses.
And we'll talk about
that in a little bit.
You can exploit hardware and
operating system support.
So there are a bunch of hardware
counters that the operating
system and hardware support--
that, for example, perf uses.
And so you folks are familiar
with the perf tool set.
Those are basically using
hardware and operating system
support.
And you can also
simulate the program.
You can run it as a
simulation, and then
you really can go
in and do anything
you want to understand.
But of course, it's
much, much slower,
and you hope that your
simulator is modeling everything
that's have relevance to you.
Maybe it's not modeling
something that turns out
to be relevant for you.
So I'm going to talk it
give some examples of each
of these five things.
So let's start with
the time command.
So it can measure elapsed time,
user time, and system time
for an entire program.
Does anybody know what
these three terms mean?
Elapsed time, user
time, and system time.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: Is elapsed
time [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Yeah, it's
what we call wall clock time.
Good.
AUDIENCE: User time is how
long a program runs [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
It's in the kernel working
on your stuff, as opposed
to somebody else's.
So that's exactly right.
So when you run
the time command,
you get some numbers like
this where it says here's
the real time,
here's the user time,
and here's the system time.
Now, you might think that the
user time and the system time
should add up to
your total time.
Uh-uh-- doesn't work that way.
And part of the reason
is that it may--
the processor may actually
not be working on your code.
You may be contact switched
out and something else is in.
So in any case, we have
those three types of things--
war clock time, the amount
of processing time spent
in the user mode code
within your process,
and the systems time, which is
the time spent in the kernel,
but within your process--
for example, satisfying
system calls and such.
Now, the timing call
that I recommend you use,
and that was used in the example
that I gave, is clock_gettime.
In particular, there are a
bunch of options to that,
and the one that I strongly
recommend is CLOCK_MONOTONIC.
And it takes about
83 nanoseconds
to actually read
what the time is.
That's about two
orders of magnitude
faster than a system call.
And one of the
things about it is--
this is such a funny
thing to have to say--
is that guarantees
never to run backwards.
Turns out the other
timers can run backwards.
You can take measurements and
discover they're negative.
This one does not run backwards.
Part of it is because
some of the other timers
do things like, oh, there's
this national standards thing
that, periodically,
your computer goes out
to find out what
the real time is,
and it resets its clock to
be consistent with whatever
the global clock is.
And that will cause
the clock to be updated
in a non-standard way, and where
suddenly you lost some time
or gained some time.
So this is really
the [INAUDIBLE]..
The only unfortunate
thing about this
is that it is non-deterministic
how long it takes.
And let me explain a little
bit what's going on in this.
So what happens is it
takes a measurement--
it has to take two
measurements to figure out
what the elapsed time is to find
out what the actual time is.
It can't just take
one measurement
because it may have
been swapped out.
And the kernel helps support,
in user space, something
that says, here's the
total amount of time
you've spent up until you
started your time slice.
So when you read that, you
have to read those two values.
Well, how do you
know that you don't
have an atomicity violation?
You read one of the values,
you got switched out,
you get switched back
in-- now, you have
a new value for the other one.
So the way it does it is
it reads this register.
It reads what the
operating system
has kept as its cumulative
time, it reads the clock,
and then it reads
that register again.
And if those two
things differ, it
knows there's been
a switch in there.
If they're the
same, it knows there
isn't, and that the number
that it can take is reliable.
So in that kind of
case, it will actually
take two measurements--
more than one measurement.
You do it again and you could
have another context switch.
And you could do it
again, and have another--
but this thing is
generally pretty fast.
And on my laptop, it takes
about 83 nanoseconds to run.
There's a lot of people say,
well, why don't I just read
the cycle counter?
That's actually cheaper.
It runs in about 32 nanoseconds.
And that you can
do with the rdtsc--
read the timestamp counter--
instruction.
And you can do it yourself
by using a built-in assembly.
And what it does is
it returns to how many
clock cycles since
the boot, and it
runs in about 32 nanoseconds.
But why not use this?
Well, one thing
is that rdtsc may
give different answers
on different cores
on the same machine--
so the cycle counters on a
processor by processor basis.
Sometimes tsc runs
backwards, as I mentioned.
And also, the counter may not
progress at a constant speed.
So remember that
the time between--
the system is possibly
slowing and speeding up
the counters, and so forth.
And converting clock cycles,
for that reason, to seconds
can be very tricky.
So I recommend you stay
away from this faster
counter, this faster timer.
The other one is don't
use gettimeofday.
That's the one most people know.
That gives you
microsecond precision.
It's not actually
microsecond accurate,
but it gives you
microsecond precision.
Because it has similar problems,
whereas this particular--
the clock_gettime MONOTONIC
has been very well engineered,
in my opinion, to give
good reliable numbers
at a reasonable cost.
Any questions about
that, about taking
measurements and what to use?
This stuff, by the way, over
time, it's going to change.
People are going to come up
with better ways or worse ways.
Or they'll say, we're not
going to support that anymore,
or what have you.
And then, if you're out
there as an engineer,
you're going to be on your own.
Hopefully you know what
some of the issues here are
and you're prepared
to be on your own.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
So when it does that,
it aggregates and the
operating system has to do it.
Those numbers
actually are very--
are relatively coarse grained.
You cannot time something
that's very short--
with time, for example--
with the time command.
In general, my experience is
you should, even with something
like-- you can get very fairly
fine grained measurements
with the clock_gettime.
You can get fairly
good measurements
there, but unless you're
aggregating, unless you're
running code that's running
around a second, certainly
at least a 10th of a second--
if you're not running
things that are that long,
you run the risk that you've
got really, really bad--
you get unlucky.
Let me point that out in
this particular example.
So here's the
interrupting strategy,
which we talked about briefly.
This is where I just
Control-C at random intervals.
And you look at
the stack and say,
who needs a fancy profiler?
In fact, there are
large companies
who use this for debugging
their big, big codes.
Facebook comes to mind.
They actually use
this technique.
It is a really easy worthwhile
technique for figuring out
where time is being spent.
Now, there are
some other things.
The Poor Man's
Profiler-- and people
have built things like gprof
and so forth to increment--
to automate the strategy so
you get this information.
Because then it
automatically [INAUDIBLE]
looks at the stack,
what's being executed,
puts that into a call
graph and so forth,
and figures out where
the time is going.
But neither of those
programs is accurate,
if you don't obtain
enough samples.
And just to give you an example,
gprof samples only 100 times
per second.
So if you're going to use gprof
for timing something that's
only a second long, you
only got 100 samples.
How many samples is 100?
That's not actually a real lot.
And so you get wildly inaccurate
numbers from interrupting.
But on the other hand,
for a quick type--
we use gprof all the time.
It's quick.
We do Control-C all the time.
It's really quick.
I don't have to
install anything.
I just take a look, and it
gives me a first cut it at what
I want to do.
It all depends.
You don't need all the
surgically precise tools
all the time.
Sometimes a really dumb tool
is adequate for the job,
and a lot quicker to deal with.
Hardware counters-- so one of
the nice things that's happened
in recent years is that there
has become available a library
called libpfm4, which is
virtualizing all the hardware
counters so that you have
access to them with--
to all of these types of
events on a per process basis.
So normally, there's
the hardware counters,
but then you switch to some--
if there's context switching
going on to some other process,
then what happens
to your counters?
They have to be saved,
they have to be updated.
So anyway, libpfm4 does all
of that kind of virtualization
to make it so that the
counter-- you can view it
as if it's your own counter.
And perf stat, for
example, employs that.
There are a lot of
esoteric hardware counters.
And as I say, good
luck in figuring out
what they all measure,
because they often
are not well-documented.
A few of the important
ones are well-documented,
but most of them are
very poorly documented
exactly what it does.
A really good example
was we had somebody
who was looking at cache
misses to figure out
how much bandwidth-- so
last level cache, L3 cache
misses to count
how much data was
being transferred from DRAM.
And they were getting
curious numbers
that didn't seem to measure up.
And it's like, wait a minute,
have a miss, moves from DRAM
onto the chip.
Why is that not
counting how much
stuff is being
moved, if I count up
how many cache misses times how
many bytes in the cache line?
Which is what, on the
machines we're using?
How many bytes in a cache line
on the machines we're using?
OK, 64.
OK, gotcha, you guys are--
But not every machine has that.
But anyway, so why was this
not measuring how much stuff
is being moved?
I'll give you a hint.
It used to measure how
much stuff was being moved,
but then those architects, they
are such pesky, clever people,
and they put in a great feature.
AUDIENCE: Prefetching.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Prefetching.
They put it in prefetching.
There's things that
fetch it, and it
doesn't update that counter.
So if you want, you have to
count how many prefetching
incidents you have, as well.
So you can often cobble
this together, but good luck
figuring out what
some of these do.
Also, watch out.
You may think that the tools let
you measure a lot of counters,
if you want.
But if you read
the fine print, it
turns out that, if you do
more than four or five,
it starts essentially time
sharing the available counting
bandwidth that it has, and it's
not-- it's actually just doing
something statistical, rather
than actually counting them.
So you can't count more than
like four or five-- actually,
four or five I think
is a high number.
But somebody I know well,
who knows this stuff,
said four or five is
probably what it is today.
So that's hardware counters.
So hardware counters
are good technique.
Next one is simulators.
So things like
cachegrind usually
run much slower than
real time, but what's
great about simulators is you
can get repeatable numbers out
of them.
You run the code.
You run it again.
If you've set up everything
right, you can get--
and you can see what's
going on inside.
The downside is that they don't
necessarily-- it's slower,
and it doesn't necessarily
model everything
going on in the cache.
But for things
like cache misses,
this is a great tool
to just figure out
what's the fundamental cache--
and we'll talk about that
when we talk about caches
in the next couple of weeks.
And if you want a
particular statistic,
in principle, you can
go in, and if it's
an open-source simulator
like cachegrind is,
you can collect it without
perturbing the simulation.
So any question about these
ways of collecting measurements?
There are a whole bunch
of ways of doing it-- they
all have pros and cons.
They all can be useful
in a given context.
They all have some flaws.
A really good strategy--
I'll talk about this
later-- is triangulation.
I never take one
measurement and believe it.
I always want to take at
least two measurements
in different ways,
and make sure they're
telling me the same story--
triangulation.
If there's a
discrepancy, then I want
to know what's causing
the discrepancy.
But I never trust one number,
and I never trust any numbers
without having a model for
what I think is coming up.
And in fact, that's
what we're going to talk
about next is
performance modeling.
So any questions about
measurements and such?
Isn't it good we have AWS run?
Number comes back,
it's the number.
And it's actually a
pretty good number.
We've worked very hard to make
that a pretty good number.
So performance
modeling-- so yeah,
we cover a lot of stuff in this
class, as I think some of you
have started to notice.
But really,
performance-- software
performance engineering
is pretty simple process.
You take a program that you
want to make go fast, program A.
You make a change to program A
to produce a hopefully faster
program A prime.
You measure the performance
of program A prime.
If A prime beats A, then
you said A equals A prime.
And if A is still not fast
enough, you repeat the process.
That's basically
what you're doing.
It's pretty simple.
And as should be apparent, if
you can't measure performance
reliably, it's hard to make
many small changes that add up,
because it's hard to tell
whether A beats A prime--
sorry, whether A prime
beats A. It's hard to tell.
And so as a consequence,
what we want to do is we
want a model of performance
that we're in a position
to draw accurate conclusions.
So we want to do things
like drive the variability
of measurement down to 0.
And we want to do
things like figure
out ways of using
statistics to give us
more accurate picture
of what's going
on then maybe what is apparent.
And that's basically
what we're going
to talk about for a little bit.
Part of what I'm going to do is
going to talk about statistics.
How many people have had a
statistics class, or a machine
learning class,
or something where
you dealt with statistics?
Beyond probability, I mean.
I mean real statistics, sample
means, and things like that.
So a few of you.
OK.
The basics of what
you need to know you
can find from
Wikipedia, or MathWorld,
or someplace like that.
And I'm not going to try to
teach you Statistics 101,
but I will point you
in some directions,
and give you some pointers
to some tools you can do.
OK, so here's a puzzle.
Suppose you measure
the performance
of a deterministic
program 100 times
on a computer with some
interfering background noise.
What statistic best
represents the raw performance
of the software?
Is it the mean of the-- the
arithmetic mean of those runs?
Is it the geometric
mean of those runs?
Is it the median of the runs?
Is it the maximum of the runs?
Is that the minimum of the runs?
This is where it's helpful,
if we had those clickers
or whatever they have.
But we don't, so I
ask people to vote.
Now, I want everybody to vote.
And once again,
it doesn't matter
if you're right or wrong.
You can be right for
the wrong reasons.
You can be wrong, but
have the idea right.
But it's fun when everybody
participates-- certainly
more fun for me when I see hands
go up than when I see people
sitting there looking bored.
OK, how many people think
arithmetic mean would
be a good way of measuring
the raw performance?
Arithmetic mean.
That's the most common
statistic that we ever gather.
OK, what about geometric mean?
OK.
What about median?
OK, good.
What about maximum?
One for maximum.
What about minimum?
OK.
So turns out that actually,
these are all good
measures to take, and
it depends upon what
you're doing with them.
But turns out minimum is--
does the best it
noise rejection.
And that's because you expect
any measurements higher
than the minimum, if it's a
deterministic program and so
forth, that's going
to be due to noise.
So if you're really
interested in knowing
how long fundamentally your
code takes on the underlying
hardware, when there's
other things going on,
taking the minimum rejects it.
Now, you might say, the
median also rejects noise,
but it doesn't, because if
you view your program as being
its running time plus
noise, then the median
is going to give
you some number that
is in the midst of the noise.
It's going to have
some component.
So minimum is the only one that
really rejects all of them.
But they're all useful
measures in different contexts.
And there are ways that you
can use the mean and some
of these other ones, as
we'll talk about in a minute,
to get information
about making decisions,
because is the thing
that we're after is not
necessarily always the raw
performance of the software.
Sometimes we're interested
in whether A beats
B. That's a different
question than how fast is this
fundamentally go.
Now, so there are a lot of
different types of summary
statistics, and there's lots of
reasons to pick different ones.
So for example, if you're
interested in serving
as many requests as possible
in a web server, for example,
you're going to be looking
at something like the CPU
utilization and taking
the arithmetic mean
to try to understand
how those things add up.
If all tasks have
to be completed
within 10 milliseconds,
then you're
going to look at the--
you're looking at the total,
and you're going to
add it up, and you're
going to be interested in making
sure that each one is small.
And that's also
what the mean does.
And you're going to be
looking at wall clock time.
If you want to ensure that
most requests are satisfied
within 100
milliseconds, you might
be looking at the 90th
percentile behavior.
And you'll say, yes, I
won't make every one,
but I want 90% of the time
I want to get it there,
and I'll be using something
like walk clock time.
In a lot of web
companies, there's
a thing called a
service level agreement.
This is what they should
give you for your telephone,
but they don't.
Tells you what kind of
service you can expect,
and if they don't meet
that service requirement,
then they haven't
lived up to it.
Instead, we buy these phones
and we get the service,
and we just get whatever
they decide to give us.
But if you're a big
company, you insist
that you get some kind of
service out of the people
that you're using.
And so there that's typically
some weighted combination,
and you're using
multiple things.
You might want to
fit into a machine
with 100 megabytes of memory,
some sort of embedded machine
or whatever, then you're going
to be interested in maximum
of the memory use.
So it's not all the
performances, not
all just time.
You might want the
least cost possible,
and you're looking at
things like energy use,
et cetera, or the fastest,
biggest, best solutions.
You can see average comes
up a lot as one of the ways.
So I wanted to though cover
one particular example, which
I find is the most commonplace
I see a misuse of summary
statistics, and that's for
when I'm summarizing ratios.
So suppose I have
two programs A and B,
and I run the four trials.
Normally, you'd run a lot more,
but I wanted to fit on a slide.
And program A, on whatever trial
1 was, took nine seconds, say.
On trial 2, it took 8--
2 and 10.
And program B you've
got 3, 2, 20, and 2.
So I can compute the
mean for each of those.
So the mean of the program A is
8.25, and the mean of program B
is 4.75 over those
four benchmarks.
I can also take a look at
how much is A winning--
sorry, is B winning over A.
And so if I take the ratios,
I then get 3, 4, 1/10,
and 5 for a mean of 3.13.
It's actually
3.125, but I'm only
keeping things to two digits.
And so if I was asked
to summarize this,
I could perhaps
conclude that program 3
is more than three times
better than program A,
based on these statistics.
But there's a bug
in that reasoning.
Can anybody see the bug?
This is wrong.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
It doesn't make sense
to take the arithmetic
mean of a bunch of ratios.
Why's that?
Yeah, one thing
here is that you can
see is that-- notice that
the mean of the ratio
is not the same as
the ratio of the mean.
That should be suspicious.
Should I not be comparing
the ratio of the mean,
or should I be comparing
the mean of the ratios?
So that's not particularly good.
Another thing is suppose I take
a look at the ratio B over A,
and I take the arithmetic mean.
Then what I discover
is that A is better
by a factor of almost
three than B. So clearly,
taking the average of the means
is the average of the ratios.
There's something
wrong with that.
And in particular, as I
say, the ratio of the means
is not the mean of the ratios.
And then your
intuition is spot on.
Suppose instead I compute
the geometric mean.
So geometric mean is
basically like taking
the average of the logs, the
arithmetic mean of the logs.
So you're basically
taking the product
and taking the n-th
root of the product.
And I've computed
that for these things.
And now I've taken
the arithmetic mean
of the run times,
because that makes sense.
That's kind of an average
over these things,
how long did things take.
And now I look at A over B and
B over A, I get the same thing.
And it's, in fact, the case
that the ratio of the means
is the mean of the ratios.
So when you look
at ratios, there's
another place that comes
up where you look at rates.
And I've seen people
look at rates,
and it turns out when you're
looking at rates, often
it's the harmonic mean
that you want in order
to preserve these good
mathematical properties,
and make sure that--
it's really bad
if I do this thing
and I say, look how
much better A is than B,
and somebody-- if I
flipped the ratio,
B would be better than
A. That's really suspect
If the identity of
whether you're A or B,
and which one was the numerator,
which in the denominator
had an impact, that
would be really suspect.
So this is the
kind of thing, when
you're thinking about how
you're reporting things
and so forth, you want to be
careful about, when you're
aggregating things,
to make sure that you
have the basic mathematical
properties met.
And what's nice is 1 divided
by 1.57 here is, in fact, 0.64.
So it didn't matter which
way I took the ratio--
I got the same answer.
So B is better that by
a factor of about 1.6,
something like that.
It was a little bit better.
It's not three times better.
And it for sure isn't the
case that A is better than B
by a factor of three.
OK, good.
Any questions about that?
Good, OK.
Suppose as I want to compare
two programs, A and B, which
is faster, and I have a
slightly noisy computer on which
to measure their performance.
What's a good strategy?
What's a good strategy for
comparing and figuring out
whether A is better than
B, or B better than A?
Sure.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Sorry, so you're saying
I'm going to run multiple runs?
That's a great idea.
We're going to do multiple runs.
And what am I doing
for each of these runs?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: The
low order statistic of the--
for example, minimum or 10%
or something really low.
OK.
So I take that.
I have one number for program
A. I have one number for program
B. I ran them n times.
What else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Well, am I comparing
the two minimums I've got there,
or am I comparing each one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Oh,
I see what you're saying.
Take all the measurements
that go below your 10%--
cheapest ones-- and
then compare those.
OK.
So you're substantially doing
noise reduction is what you're
saying, and then
other than that,
you're comparing
by comparing means.
OK, that's an
interesting methodology.
You'd probably get something
reasonable, I would think,
but you couldn't prove
anything about it.
But that's an interesting idea.
Yeah, that's an
interesting idea.
What else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You run both, and
then see which one is faster
and mark it.
And then run them both again,
see which one is faster,
mark it again-- mark that one.
And keep doing that, and then
see how many marks [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Good, so you're
saying to a bunch of
head-to-head runs,
and mark just who wins
over those things.
So one wins more than the
other, or the other wins more
than the one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
What good is that?
AUDIENCE: If the time it takes
for each program to finish
is a random variable that
tells you [INAUDIBLE]
or how much more [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Yeah.
So this is actually
a very good strategy
and actually has some
statistical muscle behind it.
So what you can do is do
n head-to-head comparisons
between A and B. So in
both these examples, yeah,
we better run it a few times.
And suppose that a
wins more frequently.
So now, what we want to do in
the statistics, where they call
the null hypothesis,
is that B beats A.
So even though we see A beats B,
the null hypothesis that we're
wrong, and that A beats--
that B beats A.
And what we then cannot
calculate is what they call
the p-value, which is the
probability we'd observe that
B--
that A beats B more
often than we did.
So for example,
for each of these--
to imagine that
in the worst case,
let's just say that they
were equal in performance,
and all we're
seeing is the noise.
Then I would expect
that I would get
about an even number of things.
And so the further that I
deviate from them being even,
especially once I--
that distribution is essentially
a Bernoulli distribution.
The further I get out--
or a T distribution,
if you have small numbers.
As I get further out from--
away from the mean by what
the variance of just flipping
coins, in that case,
I can calculate what's
the probability that
I'm seeing something
that would be that extreme.
And that gives me a good reason
to reject the null hypothesis,
if it turns out that
deviates by a lot.
So this is very standard
stuff in the social sciences.
Who's had a course in
this kind of stuff,
in testing null hypothesis,
biology, and so forth?
You remember anything from it?
Just vaguely?
Yeah, yeah.
OK, that's fine.
One of the things I
have found in life
is that I don't
remember anything I
learned in college to speak of.
What I had to do is relearn it,
but I relearned it a lot faster
than when I was in college.
And so that's part
of this is also-- so
when you see it again--
oh, OK, now, you know
how to go about learning this.
Once again, you can look this
up on Wikipedia or whatever,
if you want to use
this methodology.
It's a good one for being
able to determine, even
in the presence of noise.
What it does do is
it doesn't tell you
what the raw
performance was, but it
says, in that environment,
which one is actually faster.
And that may actually be
a more relevant question,
because you're not
always going to have
this completely quiet system.
You may have a lot of
noise going on in a system.
You'd like to know which one
is going to behave better
in what that actual system is.
And so this methodology
is pretty good.
Note that, with a lot of
noise, we need lots of trials.
The last thing that I
want to talk about--
which I won't-- is
fitting to a model.
And this is the issue of
sometimes you measure things,
but you're interested
in a derived statistic,
such as, in this case,
gathering some time,
counting instructions,
counting cache misses,
counting time, and
asking, OK, what's the--
what can I estimate is
the instruction time,
and what is the cache time?
And to do that, you do a
least-squares approximation.
And there's, once again,
some statistics behind that.
I'm not going to
go over it here,
but you can look in the notes.
There are a bunch of
issues with modeling,
which is that you can
over fit very easily.
If you add more basis functions,
you will fit the data better.
And so how do you know
if you're overfitting?
Answer is, if you
remove a basis function,
it doesn't affect the
quality very much.
Is the model predictive?
I'm actually going
to just let you
guys look at these,
because it's pretty good.
I think they're pretty
self-explanatory.
Let me just finish
with a couple of words
from a giant of science.
This is Lord Kelvin.
What is Kelvin famous for?
Besides Kelvin.
He was the guru of measurement.
And he said, to
measure is to know.
That's a good one.
And he said also, if you
cannot measurement it,
you cannot improve it.
So both very apt sayings
from the same guy,
so there's a reason he's
got a big forehand, I guess.
So anyway, that's it.
Thanks very much.
And good luck on
the quiz on Tuesday.